Wireless charging seems so great, I plug this
thingy in and then set this other thingy on
it…
BAM power!
But how the heck does electricity get from
the wall into my phone?
Hello everyone!
Trace here for DNews, thanks for stopping
by!
You're probably watching this show via a device
that has a battery.
Laptops, mobile phones, toothbrushes, though…
not this new watch everyone's talking about
for some reason…
All these things need charging and for the
moment we're still using cords and plugs for
this…
Inductive charging isn't new, it's been used
since the early 1990s in electric toothbrushes,
and for surgically implanted devices like
artificial hearts.
You've even heard of this in pop culture!
In the late 1800s, Tesla was allegedly able
to power light bulbs with no wires, and claimed
to be able to transmit power from one location
to another with no wires…
To make it work relies on simple physics.
If you ever wrapped a coil of wire around
a nail and attached a battery, then you know
the electricity in the battery runs through
the wire creating an electromagnetic field,
or flux.
Do it at home, it's fun and you can use it
to pick up paperclips or whatever.
With that same principle, a coil of wire…
magnet… battery… you can make it go the
other way too.
Spin a magnet in the coil and you'll GENERATE
electricity by taking that magnetic flux and
moving it through that coil to create electricity.
The battery creates a stable electromagnet
because it's direct current, it's going one
way.
The power from your walls is alternating current,
changes direction 60 times a second -- or
cycles at 60 hertz -- so the electrons are
moving back and forth -- remember that because
that's the key to the charging.
Wireless inductive charging gets its name
from that magnetic field interaction, called
induction.
Inside of the charging pad, and the inductive
charging device are tiny coils of wire.
The pad, being plugged into the wall, is fully
powered -- and the power is cycling.
When the other coils come within a short distance
their flux will interact with the flux in
the device, move the electrons around and
charge the battery.
Chances are, the number of cycles per second
isn't going to be 60 hertz, but like, 5 or
10, so it doesn't mess up other things in
your house.
Your WiFi network cycles at 2.4 gigahertz
or 2.4 billion cycles per second, so it's
DEFINITELY not going to mess THAT up, but
with all the radio waves flying around, you
can't be too careful.
If it's that easy, you'd think it would be
everywhere, but the problem is efficiency.
You waste a lot of power filling up two coils
and letting them talk to each other.
It's SO much better to just plug right in.
The future of wireless charging is unclear.
It seems like a great idea, but it's still
going to be a short-distance system for a
while.
In 2006, MIT found if you match the frequencies
of the devices, you can make the power go
a few METERS -- so if you were in your living
room, and a charger was there -- your phone
would charge right in your pocket…
They're working on marketing the technology
now, but it's still not everywhere…
Mr. Tesla, we're getting there, man.
Speaking of awesome innovations - how about
ones that make flying a little less suckier?
That happens to be the focus of discussion
on THIS episode of Anyhoo, hosted by my friend
Catie Wayne.
Check it out!
Back to wireless charging - what would you
want to power wirelessly?
I'd love to beam power to my TV!
Then I could put it anywhere!
Down with cables!
Leave your comments down below, Please subscribe
and thanks for watching!